I want to talk to you today about comedy
and sheltered people and completely
screwed up senses of humor one of the
most interesting psychological and
cultural phenomena that we can look at
right now is what right-wingers think is
funny now we've talked about before how
when right-wingers have tried to do
satirical news it just like doesn't work
and part of it is you can't really tell
the difference from actual right-wing
news because it's all so dumb and stupid
and shows like the half hour news hour
on Fox News failed you know you've got
this guy Greg Gutfeld on Fox News who I
guess is a comedian you can't tell when
he's doing a comedy bit and when he's
being serious he right-wing comedy just
it doesn't really work in a normal way
I am now going to present to you sort of
the latest edition of what the hell are
these people thinking I bring you today
a clip from this reawaken America Tour
these are these events that are held in
uh sort of like circus tents that are
kind of like churches all over the place
many of these are affiliated with
Christian hate preacher Greg Locke they
brought in comedian Jim Brewer Jim
Brewer is now I guess you can call him a
right-wing comedian and what is amazing
to me is he mocks flu shots he mocks
vaccines he seems to mock Demar Hamlin
the NFL player who recently suffered a
cardiac arrest on on the field and
thankfully is is moving ahead in his
recovery and the crowd just loves it the
this is comedy to these people and it is
extraordinarily sad in terms of what it
says about our country take a look at
this still have my in-laws my in-laws
like we gotta get our flu shot then a
booster
done another booster
this guy's clapping this guy isn't he's
in stitches folks if you're listening
there's a Vietnam veteran hat wearing
guy
who is just clapping he's he's he's he's
so uh he's he's almost apoplectic in
laughter
it's starting to die where'd you hear
that right
what are you one of those conspiracy
gifts
whoa
the left had better be ready for this
because the right is starting to get
good at comedy look at these young
ladies who were just overcome with
laughter
[Music]
[Laughter]
what are you a cult member
extremists winning
I guess this is an imitation of a left
Winger that Jim Brewer is doing I don't
know
[Laughter]
so I guess the joke he falls down Jim
Brewer throws himself down on the ground
like like a tantruming two-year-old I
guess the joke is oh everything's fine
with the vaccines oh whoops Demar Hamlin
is now down on the ground
I think the joke is that the vaccine
caused what happened to Damar Hamlin of
course for which there's no evidence I
again I'm trying to interpret stuff that
is unintelligible I believe that's the
joke to the extent that it's a joke that
Jim Brewer is making
and that really gets the crowd right
riled up
[Applause]
isn't this great guys
[Music]
crazy conspiracy theorist
all right so then the same then the same
bit just starts over again only the most
sheltered people would find this stuff
funny
if
you are if you if your entertainment
and your thinking is mostly watching
paint dry
maybe this is funny because Brewers
making you know like a silly face but
it's disturbing and it's pathetic and
it's really disheartening to see what is
considered funny these days among the
right and these Trends we mock vaccines
and we mock people who get them and we
mock doctors and you know the last time
we talked about Jim Brewer about a year
ago he was making fun of people who
listened to doctors but even Brewer
himself when his wife was was very sick
I forget what with I think it was a type
of cancer he wasn't mocking doctors then
or Specialists or any of it he found the
best people and he went to them and he
listened to them so that he could
actually get treatment so even Brewer
this may even be an act as far as Brewer
is concerned but it reveals this deep
ignorance this deep lack of empathy
towards struggles that people have
towards people affected by the pandemic
people health care workers
and on and on and on but it's also a
reflection of a larger problem within
the right wing and this increased
tendency to retreat into their Echo
Chambers because this is now no longer
even just well different news sources
and different underlying beliefs about
ABCD issue this this is about we are
going to surround ourselves with people
so delusionally like-minded that it
becomes an impossibility to ever break
out of this right if you're laughing
this hard as hard as this woman is
laughing at the act that Jim Brewer is
doing I don't know how you ever get out
of that Echo chamber and I don't know
how how our society can actually move
forward in any kind of constructive
Manner and I hate that I have become so
cynical and negative about this but
I am very NE I'm very pessimistic about
it I mean when you see this laughter
at what I just played for you
uh I I don't know where we go from here
let me know what you think in the
comments